was the intention
always to kind of have an origin story
leading up to what ends up being the
very first case
um in the perry mason lore absolutely
not so much the first case the idea was
to
initially tell the story of perry as an
outsider taking on
these larger systems and we were
figuring out how best to do that
and at the same time recognizing we
really didn't know much
about his backstory we only ever be it
in the books or other shows
met him as the lawyer so our writers had
this idea of
okay you guys want him to be sort of an
outsider we want to learn more about
what made him
this great lawyer let's just not make
him a lawyer yet
let's just lead up to him kind of coming
into that situation
because he is so dogged in his pursuit
of justice that he becomes
almost by default the best person for
this job and then the
the kind of wink wink at the end of it
being
that first uh case in that first book
was
was by design coming out of you know our
show runners minds
for you and you know everyone's allowed
to have their own interpretations but
what is
what is releasing the thread symbolized
to you
wow uh to me um
it's sort of been this um
rep it i think it represents his
internal journey
actually you know where we found him in
the beginning
disconnected disenfranchised paralyzed
from
whatever he came from and that gave him
purpose
and you know i i in my mind i i would
say that this is
um you see in the last shot of showing
he's letting it go right
some sort of acknowledgement goes off
into the wind and now he would move on
um so it does it's sort of just a i
thought it's emblematic of
of his journey i think intentionally
symbolic of his
evolution you know it's an early piece
of evidence that he gets
he see him try to pursue it in a way
that he thought would
be easy and quickly learns that there's
nothing that's going to be easy about
this case and yet he holds on to that
symbol
um and so by the end there is there is
something he's
he's freeing and quite honestly you
could take it a step further
and outside of perry and what it means
to him
but he always wanted justice justice for
charlie dodson and there's a part of him
that
that is freeing charlie i think as well
at that moment
right yeah i mean you know truly is a
talisman
yeah exactly um
really quickly because i'm running out
of time uh do you see
it let's say in a far-off future where
everything everything's
nothing shut down anymore uh do you see
a future
for season two with uh sister alice
still involved
what's always great is you build these
characters in season one and we have
incredible characters whether it was
you know eb which is john lithgow's
character you have
um what tatiana brought in and you know
viewed in sister alice
or even what veronica brought to lupe
you know there
there are some of these characters where
you you come away and you go we gotta we
gotta find a way to get him into season
two
um you know once we dig deeper and and
if we have the opportunity i think we're
going to
see what remains we're gonna because
there's gonna be new arenas that we
wanna play with
and um whether or not you know
she she ends up on this next leg of the
journey or maybe comes back
even further down the road i think it
remains to be seen
we just have the same instinct and
understand why you asked the question
because we're so
in love and fascinated with her even up
to the very very last
you know moments so i get it but i
having been part of things that were
sequels and stuff
again you always leave that first one
because you're so in love and say we're
bringing this person back we're bringing
this person
and all for the right reasons because
they worked um
and then but you really have to start
what what's what's this
story and journey of our
three leads and what are the themes we
want to play with and then that has to
kind of
dictate the worlds we go in and the
other characters that end up populating
it so
um sort of a long way of saying we'll
see